Hey Youtubers it's Charlie! Huge news for Legend Of Korra tonight.
So they're airing all 4 final episodes tonight. Janet Varney made the announcement on
Tumblr.
They said that if they could get 10,000
reblogs they would air the final two
episodes
a week early on Nick.com at midnight
tonight. This video will be a review of
episodes 11 and 12, and then I'll do a
separate review for episode 13 and 14.
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get it. Since
there's so much awesome Korra to get
through tonight, let's do our favorite
moments real quick
and then I'll do my review. First off,
high five yourself if you guessed
Dark Avatar.
Unalaq explained that once Harmonic Convergence started he would fuse with Vaatu.
And because they would be in perfect
alignment they would be a much more
powerful Avatar
than Raava and Korra would be. This
doesn't explain how he can be the Avatar
without having all four elements.
But I think that the show runners just
want to imply that Vaatu would give him
that ability just like Raava kind of held
all four element for Wan.
But that doesn't confirm whether or not
there will actually be a Dark Avatar.
We'll find out in those last two episodes
though.
So we got to see Harmonic Convergence and
the visual effect as well as the
soundtrack during a lot of the scenes
was amazing.
Watching that wave of dark energy just
envelope the entire planet.
If you're confused about what that means, it
means when Harmonic Convergence happens it
basically amplifies spiritual energy so
any spirits walking around now are 10
times more powerful. It doesn't explain
whether all benders become more powerful,
but spirits definitely become more
powerful.
That's why Vaatu is able to break out
of his tree prison. That classic Fire
Ferrets scene at the end was also amazing
obviously Bolin kind of had his moment
the beginning of the episode in the arena.
Bolin and Mako were basically running a
block on Unalaq while Korra was trying to
close the portal.
She didn't do it in time, but it was still
amazing seeing Classic Fire Ferrets.
Fire Ferrets Ride or Die!
Next up, my two favorite characters in
these two episodes were
1 - Bolin, or should I say Nuktuk, Sky Warrior.
And 2- Bumi with his flute. The last couple
episodes Bolin's characters kind of got
pushed to the side while Korra deals with
her spiritual mis alignment or tries to
get realigned with Raava.
So was awesome to watch him get his big
hero moment in the arena. Especially
when the
action on-screen started a mirror the
action in the arena.
I actually thought that the Bolin and Asami were going to hook up in that first episode,
but it turns out Masami is still a
thing. But I'll talk about that during my
funniest moments.
So Bumi was my favorite character from
Harmonic Convergence.
Not only did he inception Team Korra with
the aerial assault idea,
he also took out the entire southern
encampment guarding the portal.
Obviously it was a funny scene too,
but we learned that you can pacify
spirits with music.
So obviously not all spirits, because that
led to that big destruction scene.
But I think that his flute is going to come in
handy later or its going inform some of
the character's strategy.
Raise your hand if you that the
soundtrack during that whole Bumi
destruction seen when he climbed in the
Mech was amazing!
The sound just picked up and was perfect
for that scene. It was
hilarious and the action was amazing.
As a side note, I'll also probably be doing a
giveaway for the Korra soundtrack
whenever they release the Book 2
soundtrack.
As for my funniest scenes in the episodes
though, even though Bumi kind of brought
most of the comedy,
the Masami VS Makorra specially
in that first episode
was amazing. Write below in the comments, "How many different expressions do you think
went across Mako's face
when he tried to deal with Korra and
Asami. It must have been at least 20.
20 expressions of awkward in under 30 seconds,
it was hilarious. Poor Mako... He brought
this on himself though.
But the big questions we had after this
episode and before the Finale are
1 - Will Unalaq fuse with Vaatu and how
wil Korra stop them if they do become the
Dark Avatar? Remember they're supposed to
be more powerful than she and Raava
together.
2 - How will they save Jinora? We didn't see Jinora in this episode, but she's still
in the spirit world. 3 - Will the twins
betray Unalaq and help Team Korra?
and 4 - What will Korra do to pacify all
the dark spirits roaming around in the
human realm?
Even if she does defeat Unalaq and
Vaatu and closes the spirit portals.
That won't make the spirits go away. So
she'll still have to pacify them
and get them to go back through the
Spirit Portal into the Spirit World.
But what did I think of the episode? Overall
I give it a solid B+
It was great. I really loved the way it
took side characters
or at least main characters that hadn't
been serviced and really gave them big
moments. It paid off a lot of moments for
people like Bolin and Bumi.
They had kind of been pushed to the side for a long time. The action was great, the
soundtrack was great. It's still not as
good as Beginnings. Beginnings is still
my all-time favorite Korra episode right
now.
But it went a long way to answering some of
our biggest questions like the Dark
Avatar question.
Even though there are a bunch of questions that still remain unanswered, we'll find out
after the Finale.
Because it literally, the last two
episodes will be airing at Midnight
tonight
on Nick.com. That's Eastern Time. I'll be doing a video for that
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get it. I'll post it
right after the episode airs so will be
late tonight.
But let me know your favorite moments were
and if there was anything that you
thought was really important that I didn't
mention in the video, it was an hour
Korra so there's a lot of stuff that went on.
Be sure to write in the comments and
we'll discussify.
Right Now CLICK HERE to get my review of
the Finale. I'll add the annotation as soon as
I post the video in a couple hours.
and CLICK HERE to learn all about my
Doctor Who 50th Anniversary Giveaway.
I'm giving way DVDs so you have a chance
to win some free stuff!
High Fives! See you guys later tonight!